This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之百真人。2%。这是指在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在这样一个陌生现代世界中培养精神韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是数字2%。可在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在Look Back at it播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或任何你听播客的地方收听look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位知情且专业的持证心理咨询师进行交流。有多少男人穿着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或任何你听播客的地方收听Learn the hard way。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听Love Trapped播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们的意义。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. It has been a beautiful week for me. I am back from my mother-daughter trip to Fiji. I feel refreshed. I feel really motivated. I feel good. I literally had the best time with my mom. She is so much fun. So I feel like I'm back right in time to dive into work. Like I had enough time away to feel excited about coming back. And, you know, speaking of work, work is actually the subject of today's episode. Specifically, the signs that you may not be aware of or may be ignoring that your career is not right for you.
对我们的心理。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎新老听友再次收听本播客，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们将一如既往地剖析我们二十岁时的心理。对我和来说，这是美好的一周。我结束了斐济的母女之旅回来了。我感到神清气爽。我感到非常充满动力。我感觉很好。我和妈妈在一起度过了最棒的时光，真的。她太有趣了。所以我觉得我回来得正是时候，可以一头扎进工作里。就像我有足够的时间远离工作，从而对回来充满期待。而且，说到工作，工作其实就是今天这期节民主题。具体来说，就是那些你可能没有意识到、或者可能一直在忽视的迹象，表明你的职业并不适合你。
not just not right for you, but deeply dissatisfying, deeply unfulfilling, deeply unrewarding, and perhaps you just haven't even realized it yet. These are specifically signs that I wish someone had told me when I was feeling pretty low about my previous job and I was trying so hard to make it work. And now I can acknowledge that all those things I was feeling were actually indicative that this career was just not right for me. When I look back, you know, I wish I had made a change earlier. I wish that my decision paralysis and fear of the unknown hadn't kept me in unhappy places for longer than I needed to be in them. And so I'm taking some of that wisdom, some of the things that I
不仅仅是不适合你，而是深深地让你感到不满意、深深地让你感到毫无成就感、深深地让你感到毫无回报，也许你甚至还没有意识到这一点。这些正是我希望在我对上一份工作感到相当低落、拼命想要把它做好时，有人能告诉我的具体迹象。现在我可以承认，我当时所有的感受其实都表明，这份职业就是不适合我。回想起来，你知道的，我希望自己能早点做出改变。我希望我的决策麻痹和对未知的恐惧没有让我留在不快乐的地方，超过我原本需要待的时间。所以我吸取了其中的一些智慧，其中的一些
learned, as well as some of the tips and some of the psychology to really help you guys figure out whether what you're experiencing right now is just a bad week or a deeper dissatisfaction with what you are doing. But more importantly, the kind of warning signs that you are becoming stagnant or stuck when you know that you are not happy. Basically, how do we make a change in our career and in our lives and have the bravery and the courage to try something new before we feel further weighed down by time and money and the education and the years that we've invested into a job or a profession that, you know, simply isn't right for us. Work is really important.
学到的东西，以及一些建议和心理学知识，来真正帮助大家弄清楚你现在经历的究竟只是糟糕的一周，还是对你正在做的事情有着更深层次的不满。但更重要的是，当你明知自己不快乐时，那些表明你正在变得停滞不前或陷入困境的危险信号。基本上，在我们被工作、金钱、教育以及投入到一份并不适合我们的工作或职业中的岁月进一步拖垮之前，我们如何在职业生涯和生活中做出改变，并拥有尝试新事物的勇气和胆量呢？工作真的很重要。
Doing something you care about doesn't have to be aspirational, even in this current job market. And I want to really share how you can choose something that feels more aligned without feeling boxed in by this very notorious and incorrect idea of a dream job. I also want to talk about when you know it's really time to quit, even if maybe you don't have anything else lined up. And also some of the surprising ways that hating your job shows up in all other dimensions of your life that you may or may not be ignoring. So if you have doubts lingering as to whether what you're doing now is really
做你关心的事情并不一定非得高不可攀，即使在当前这样的就业市场也是如此。我想真正分享的是，你如何在不被这个臭名昭著且错误的“梦想工作”概念所局限的情况下，选择一件感觉更加契合的事情。我还想聊聊当你知道真的是时候辞职时该怎么办，即使你可能还没有找好下路。以及讨厌工作这一情绪如何以出人意料的方式表现在你生活的方方面面，而这些你可能正在忽视，也可能没有忽视。所以，如果你对于现在做的事是否真的是
what you want to do for the rest of your life or something that you actually care about, these five signs will definitely give you some clarity and give you some of the answers that you are probably looking for. So without further ado, whether you're in your 20s or maybe even beyond, let's get into the signs that the career you're in right now is maybe not the one for you. Stay with us. If you have listened to the podcast for a while, will probably know this, but it is my deep belief that when it comes to finding the right career, the right pathway, the right job for you, there isn't one. There is not a perfect job. There is no such thing as a dream job that comes with no flaws, no downsides, no bad days,
你余生想做的事，或者是否是你真正关心的事情，还心存疑虑，那么这五个迹象绝对能给你带来一些清晰的认识，并给你提供你可能一直在寻找的答案。废话不多说，无论你是在二十多岁还是已经过了这个年纪，让我们一起来探讨一下你目前的职业可能并不适合你的那些迹象。请继续收听。如果你听这个播客有一段时间了，你大概会知道这一点，但我深信不疑的是，当谈到寻找合适的职业、正确的道路、适合你的工作时，根本没有所谓的“唯一”。根本没有一份完美的工作。根本不存在那种没有缺点、没有负面影响、没有糟糕日子的“梦想工作”。
no occasional sense of emptiness. And that's coming from someone who, for all intents and purposes, has the best job that they could ask for in their life right now. There are still things that I would change. And I know that in 10, 20 years, I probably won't think the same about my job that I do now because dream jobs evolve. Our purpose evolves. Our idea of work-life balance is constantly being changed and being challenged.
没有偶尔的空虚感。这是由一个在各方面都拥有目前生活中所能要求的最好的工作的人说出来的。仍然有我想要改变的事情。我知道在10年、20年后，我对工作的看法可能不会像现在这样，因为梦想工作是在不断演变的。我们的目标在演变。我们对工作与生活平衡的看法也在不断改变和受到挑战。
That doesn't necessarily mean, though, that there isn't some careers out there that simply fit better. I do want to give that caveat at the beginning that if you are here to figure out what your dream job is, I'm sorry, I don't even believe in that concept, but hopefully I can bring you closer to finding a job that is maybe almost there for you. Another thing I believe is that it's never too late to change, to shift gears to essentially decide that you want something different. And at the point that you realize that your major, your job, your career isn't for you, no matter how. how far you have gone down the wrong road, turn back.
但这并不一定意味着，外面就没有更适合你的职业。我在一开始就要给出这个提醒：如果你来这里是为了找出你的梦想工作是什么，我很抱歉，我甚至不相信这个概念，但希望我能让你更接近找到一份对你来说可能差不多的工作。我坚信的另一件事是，改变永远不会太迟，改变方向、从根本上决定你想要不同的生活永远不会太迟。当你意识到你的专业、你的工作、你的职业不适合你时，无论你。在错误的道路上走了多远，回头吧。
That is a very famous Turkish proverb that I think more of us ought to live by, not just in our professional lives, but in relationships, in love, in anything. Careers in particular, though, you know, a lot feels at stake for a couple of reasons. There's a couple of reasons why we know we're on the wrong path and we don't turn around. The first one being that, you know, our jobs, they allow us to live and they, allow us to exist in a world that is ruled by currency and money. Jobs pay our bills. So simply leaving without having anything else lined up, I don't know about you. I've never had that luxury. Secondly, you may have a lot of time, energy, resources tied up in your career. Say you're
这是一句非常著名的土耳其谚语，我认为我们应该有更多人遵照它生活，不仅在我们的职业生活中，在人际关系中、在爱情中、在任何事情中都是如此。不过，尤其是职业生涯，你知道的，有很多东西悬而未决，原因有几个。有几个原因导致我们明知自己走错了路却不肯回头。第一个原因是，你知道的，我们的工作让我们得以生存，它们让我们能够在一个由货币和金钱统治的世界里存在。工作支付我们的账单。所以，在没有安排好退路的情况下直接辞职，我不知道你们怎么样。我从来没有过这种奢侈。其次，你可能在职业生涯中投入了大量的时间、精力、资源。假设你正在
becoming a doctor or a psychologist or a tradesperson. That typically means a lot of studies. That typically means a lot of study, a lot of hours learning a skill, sometimes a lot of student loans, a lot of money invested. You can really feel like you're not going to get that time back, you're not going to get that money back, you're letting yourself down, you're letting your family down, and that's what causes us to stay in places that we don't belong, simply because of basically the sunk cost effect. We also, of course, it's not just an investment of time, energy money, it's a lot. investment of our identity. What we choose to do for a living, what we hope to do for a living forms a large and significant part of who we see ourselves as. You know, what's one of the first
成为一名医生、心理学家或技术工人。这通常意味着大量的学习。这通常意味着大量的学习、花费大量时间学习一项技能，有时还要背负大量的学生贷款，投入大量的资金。你真的会觉得那些时间回不去了，那些金钱回不去了，你让你自己失望了，你让你的家人失望了，这就是为什么我们会留在不属于我们的地方，仅仅是因为沉没成本效应。当然，我们不仅投入了时间、能量和金钱，还投入了大量的身份认同。我们选择以什么为生，我们希望以什么为生，构成了我们如何看待自己的很大一部分重要内容。你知道的，首要事情之一
things that people ask you? What do you do for work? What are you studying? It just goes to show how much occupational identity is one of the ways that we are really pigeonholed and that we pigeonhole ourselves. And you know, pigeonholes may feel very small and restrictive. They can also feel very safe and very comfortable. So deciding to walk away from whatever you're studying, whatever you're doing, and explore other things, especially if you don't know what else you want to try, it can feel like voluntarily choosing to step off a ledge into a large bottomless pit. But being in the wrong place, it doesn't get easier. Your tolerance for it just improves until, you know, one day you're in your 60s and you're looking back at your life and you're realizing how truly young you were,
人们会问你什么？你是做什么工作的？你在学什么？这恰恰说明了职业认同是我们在其中被真正归类以及我们给自己归类的方式之一。而且你知道的，这些分类可能会让人觉得非常狭隘和局限。它们也可以让人觉得非常安全和舒适。因此，决定放弃你正在学习的、正在做的任何事情，去探索其他事情，尤其是如果你不知道自己还想尝试什么时，会感觉就像是自愿选择从悬崖边跳下一个无底深渊。但身处错误的位置并不会变得更容易。你对它的耐受力只会不断提高，直到有一天，你到了60岁，回首往事，你才意识到自己曾经是多么的年轻，
how much time you actually really did have ahead of you if you'd just taken the risk and walked away a little bit sooner from the thing that you knew deep down you didn't love. So to avoid that regret to give ourselves that opportunity. Let's discuss these five signs that you are probably in the wrong career. Sign one, you feel emotionally numb, you dread what you're doing and it's a feeling that goes way beyond boredom. If you dread every Monday, you feel your mood completely shift the moment you walk into work, you completely detach, you don't care if you're fired, you don't care if your work is good, you don't care if the assignment is late, just have no desire to commit or succeed in what you're doing, this is probably the wrong career
如果你早一点冒险离开那个你内心深处知道自己并不真正热爱的行业，你其实还有多少时间可以把握。因此，为了避免这种遗憾，为了给自己创造那个机会，让我们来探讨这五个表明你可能处于错误职业的迹象。迹象一，你感到情感麻木，你对正在做的事情感到恐惧，这种感觉远远超出了无聊的范畴。如果你害怕每一个周一，当你走进公司的那一刻，你会发现自己的情绪彻底发生了变化，你完全抽离了，你不在乎自己是否被解雇，你不在乎你的工作是否优秀，你不在乎任务是否迟交，你只是根本没有渴望去投入或在你所做的事情上取得成功，这可能是一份错误的职业
for you. Yes, a job isn't always going to put a fire in your belly every single day, but if this is what you're going to spend the large majority of your life doing, almost 90,000 hours of your life, according to some estimates, you want to feel something. Pride, accomplishment, that you're helping people, whatever it is, even on hard days, you want to feel. something. You don't want to feel nothing and you most certainly don't want to feel just plain anxiety. The Sunday Scaries are another indicator of this. Sunday Scaries, it's a common term. You've most likely heard of it. But if not, it essentially refers to the anxiety or dread that many people experience on a Sunday evening as the weekend ends and the work week begins. And it has a scientific explanation.
对你来说。是的，一份工作不可能每天都让你充满激情，但如果这是你将花费生命中绝大多数时间去做的事情——根据一些估计，大约是你生命中的90,000个小时——你希望去感受些许情绪。自豪感、成就感、你在帮助别人，无论是什么，即使在艰难的日子里，你也希望去感受。某种情绪。你不希望毫无感觉，你也绝对不希望仅仅感到纯粹的焦虑。“周日焦虑症”是这一现象的另一个指标。“周日焦虑症”，这是一个常见的词。你很可能听说过它。如果没有，它本质上指的是许多人在周日晚上、当周末结束而工作周即将开始时所经历的焦虑或恐惧。并且它有科学解释。
Sunday Scaries, it's essentially emotional forecasting or anticipatory dread. You're looking at the week ahead and almost feeling empathy for your future self and what you'll know they have to endure and kind of almost borrowing their unhappiness so that you feel terrible right now. And the more you experience this and endure this, the more you start to become quite numb. once you get into work or back to school or to your internship or whatever, instead of feeling all that anxiety you were feeling on Sunday, you actually end up shutting off. You go through the motions. All of this is a way to kind of mentally compartmentalize rather than really acknowledging like, wow, I really hate this. Because realizing that you really hate this means that you probably have to do
周日焦虑症，本质上是情感预测或预期性恐惧。你看着即将到来的一周，几乎是在为未来的自己感到同情，同情他们知道自己必须忍受的一切，并且几乎是在提前借用他们的不快乐，好让自己此刻感觉糟糕透顶。你经历和忍受这种情况越多，一旦你进入工作、回到学校、去实习或做其他事情，你就会开始变得相当麻木。而不是去感受你在周日感受到的所有焦虑，你最终实际上会选择关闭自己的感受。你只是在机械地走过场。所有这一切都是一种在精神上进行自我隔离的方式，而不是真正去承认诸如“哇，我真的很讨厌这个”之类的事实。因为意识到你真的很讨厌这个，意味着你可能必须为此做点什么。
something about it. And you just might not feel ready for that. So this can also be highly indicative of something else called emotional blunting where you basically become numb to what is going on around you. It's typically associated with certain medications such as antidepressants, but it can also have an environmental origin like a workplace or a job that you really hate or you feel absolutely nothing positive towards. Now, if this gets worse, this can also develop into something that psychologists call an hedonia. So a lack of interest, a lack of enjoyment, a lack of pleasure in what you're experiencing, almost like people describe it like looking at your life and feeling like there is a tinge of grey over everything. And in this context, the context of our
而你可能还没准备好面对这一点。因此，这也非常预示着另一种名为“情感钝化”的现象，即你基本上对周围发生的事情变得麻木。它通常与某些药物（如抗抑郁药）有关，但它也可能源于外部环境，比如你真的很讨厌、或者对其没有任何积极感受的工作场所或工作。如果这种情况恶化，它甚至可能发展成心理学家所称的“快感缺乏”。即对所经历的事物缺乏兴趣、缺乏享受、缺乏乐趣，几乎就像人们形容的那样，看着自己的生活，觉得一切都蒙上了一层灰色。在这种背景下，也就是我们工作和职业的背景下，它通常源于这样一种环境：你的核心价值观和兴趣被迫压抑。你甚至可能没有意识到自己变得多么情感麻木，直到周末到来，或者直到你在度假，或者直到你在做副业时，突然之间你又重新活过来了。就好像这才是你真正感觉像自己的地方。工作日期间或者任何你正在学习、或者只要你从事着不适合你的事情时的这种长期的脱节，其实是你的大脑和身体在进行交流，本质上是在说这根本不符合能让我们快乐的要求。正因为我们无法承认自己有多么不快乐，所以我们干脆什么也感觉不到。
jobs and our careers, it often stems from being in an environment where your core values and your interests are being forced to be put away. And you may not even realize how emotionally flat you've become until the weekend or until you're on holiday or until you're working on a side project and suddenly like you come alive again. It's like this is where you really feel like yourself. This kind of chronic disconnection throughout the work week or whenever you're studying or whenever you're engaged in the thing that isn't right for you, this is your mind and your body communicating and essentially saying this is this is not fitting the bill for what makes us happy. And because we can't acknowledge how unhappy we are, we're not going to feel anything.
这与你正处于错误职业生涯的第二个迹象密不可分，即你的身份认同与你正在从事的工作感觉完全不合拍。2016年发表在《职业行为杂志》上的一项研究本质上发现，职业满意度与一种被称为“身份契合度”的概念息息相关。你的工作在多大程度上反映了你是谁。你的身份契合度越高，你在做的事情中就会越快乐。几年前，甚至大概十年前，曾有过一项民意调查，发现近55%的美国人从他们的工作中获得了很大一部分身份认同。而且我认为，随着我们在办公室和工作上花费的时间逐年显著增加，我只能想象这种身份投入确实大大增加了。
This is intrinsically linked to the second sign that you are in the wrong career, which is that your identity and what you are doing for work feel entirely out of sync. A 2016 study from the Journal of Vocational Behavior, it essentially found that career satisfaction is incredibly linked to something called identity alignment. How much your job reflects who you are. The more identity alignment you have, the happier you are going to be doing what you're doing. There was a poll a couple of years ago, maybe even like a decade ago, that found almost 55% of Americans derive a really large part of their identity from their job. And I think as our time spent in the office and working, increases significantly year by year, I can only imagine that that identity investment has really
如果你珍视帮助他人，而你的工作却是在拒绝保险理赔，由于缺乏身份契合度，你将会经历深深的认知失调。如果你热爱大自然、喜欢户外活动，却从事着一间窗户也没有的办公室工作，问题也是一样的。如果你真的很看重知识分子和认知刺激，但你从事的工作却非常常规且基于流程，几乎没有发挥创造力的空间。同样，你也会出现不契合。身份上的不契合，就如同身体上的不契合一样。
increased. If you value helping others and your job is denying insurance claims, you will experience deep cognitive dissonance because you don't have identity alignment. If you love nature and you love being outdoors and you work a desk job with no windows, same issue. If you really value intellectualism, and being cognitively stimulated, but you work a job that is very routine and process-based with not much room for creativity. Again, you have a disalignment. A disalignment in your identity is the same as a disalignment in your body.
感觉相当糟糕，并且你能察觉出有什么地方不对劲。这与一个叫做“自我概念清晰度”的概念非常相似。因此，自我概念清晰度基本上是我们辨别什么能让自己快乐的能力，以及我们了解什么能让自己感到满足的能力。所以，如果你发现自己经常说这样的话：“这真的一点都不像我”、“我讨厌这个身份带给我的改变”、“我在工作时都认不出我自己了”、“我觉得自己像个别人”，这绝不是小事。这表明你的自我概念清晰度正在发挥作用，并在与你沟通，
It feels pretty terrible, and you can tell that something is wrong. This is very similar to a concept called self-concept clarity. So self-concept clarity is basically our, ability to tell what's going to make us happy and our ability to know what would make us satisfied. So if you find yourself saying things like, this just really doesn't feel like me, like I hate who this makes me, I don't recognize who I am at work, I feel like someone else, that's not trivial. That is indicative that your self-concept clarity is coming into play and is communicating with
并告诉你：“这根本不是我们。这不是我们想成为的人。”如果你过着的生活与你认为的自己不一致，你知道的，那你又是谁呢？如果我们的生活以及我们所成为的那种人是由我们的行动、我们的时间以及我们工作的地方所定义的，而所有这些其他方面却在说着相反的话、代表着与我们截然相反的形象，我们就会变得非常不快乐。你的身体以及你的自我意识的其他部分也会对此作出反应。我们通过研究得知，这种不满意会变得非常显性。它会变得非常真实地呈现在你的身体里、你的大脑里、你的骨骼里、你的肌肉里。为了找出替代方案是什么，你知道的，到底什么才能让我们更快乐？
you and telling you like, this isn't who we are. This isn't who we want to be. if you're not living your life in line with who you think you are you know who are you then like if our life and the kind of person we are is defined by our actions and our and our actions and our time and where we work and all these other things is saying the opposite and representing the opposite of who we are we are going to be very unhappy and your body and the rest of your sense of self will respond to that we know through research that this dissatisfaction becomes very tantamination becomes very tanty It becomes very felt in your body, in your mind, in your bones, in your muscles. In order to discover what the alternative would be, you know, what would actually make us happier?
我所谓的、不是这样的梦想工作会是什么？我们需要真正关注价值观，因为如果我们过着或者从事着导致不契合的职业，找回契合的唯一方法就是真正地、反复地确认我们在乎什么，然后寻找通过工作来实现这些的方法。有人曾经问过我一个问题，我认为这是做到这一点的绝佳方法。如果你正在为自己真正想在生活中做什么而苦恼，你只知道绝不是现在这样，我想这个问题会有所帮助。基本上，如果你的整个身份、你所有的记忆、关于你生活的一切、关于你作为一个人是谁的记忆都被抹去了，你现在拥有的五种价值观是什么，你会选择首先找回它们？
What would my so-called dream job be that isn't this? We really need to then focus on values because if we're living or having a career that is creating disalignment, the only way to bring back alignment is to really, really reaffirm what we care about and then find ways to seek that out. through work. This question that someone asked me once, I think, is a really great way to do that. If you're struggling with what you really want to do in your life, you just know it's not this, I think this question will help. Basically, if your whole identity, all your memories, everything about your life had been erased, about who you were as a person, had been erased, what are the five values that you have right now that you would choose to come back first?
这其实是换一种方式在问：在你内心深处，你如何看待自己？你认为哪五件事最能代表你？要求你的工作反映出这一点，难道真的那么异想天开吗？如果与你现在的处境相比，这感觉像是一种奢望，如果你的工作根本没有反映出这五件事，那么想象一下，接下来继续生活30、40年，而你的价值观却始终不契合。我认为这个练习之所以对那些不确定自己想做什么的人如此管用，是因为它并不是要求你把“梦想工作”当作替代选项来找出来。就像今天早上我在散步时和我的朋友讨论这个问题，她说：“我不知道我的梦想工作是什么。”我就说：“嗯，你大概根本没有。
It's basically a different way of asking, who do you see yourself as, like at your core? What are the five things that you think represent you the most? And is it that far-fetched that you can't ask for your work to reflect that? If that feels like a stretch from where you are now, if those five things are not reflected in your work at all, imagine then going forward and living another 30, 40 years where your values aren't aligned. The reason I think this exercise works so well for people who are like unsure of what they want to do is it's not asking you to identify your dream job as an alternative. Like I was having this discussion with my friend on a walk this morning and she was like, I don't know what my dream job is. And I was like, well, you probably don't have one.
你可能永远也弄不清楚它到底是什么。如果你穷尽一生去寻找它，你大概不会快乐。但你能做的是，弄清楚一大类你可能会觉得做起来很有成就感的事情。你知道的，这正是这个练习能让你做到的。它要求你明确自己的价值观，然后这些价值观可以通过不同的职业以不同的方式表达出来，而不仅仅局限于一件事。举个例子，如果你想找回的其中一个价值观是，比方说，脆弱感，
You probably will never figure out what it is. If you search for that your entire life, you'll probably be unhappy. But what you can do is figure out a kind of broad range of things that you'll probably will. would feel really fulfilled doing. You know, and that's what this allows you to do. It's asking you to identify your values, which can then be expressed in different ways through different careers, not just one thing. For example, if one of the values that you would want back is, let's say, vulnerability,
脆弱感作为核心价值观，意味着你可以成为一名咨询师。你也可以成为一名红娘。你可以成为一名临终关怀护士。你也可以成为一名康复总监。有很多选择，不是只有一个梦想工作，但它们都植根于你所珍视的东西。在你的工作中拥有这一点，真的是非常非常重要。同样值得一提的是，当我们从工作中获得过多的身份认同合时会发生什么，因为这确实会导致某种同样有点可怕的结果。
vulnerability as a core value could mean that you could be a counselor. You could also be a matchmaker. You could be a hospice nurse. You could be a rehab director. many options, not one dream job, but all rooted in what you value. It's really, really important that you have that in your work. It's worth mentioning as well what happens when we derive too much identity from work because that can really result in something equally kind of scary.
这叫做“情感吞没”（enmeshment），即你和你的工作永远无法分离开来。你在工作上的成功决定了你在其他任何地方的价值。你的兴趣全在工作上。你能听到人们厌烦了你整天谈论工作。你脑子里想的全是工作。我必须承认，当我刚开始全职做播客时，我也陷入了这个陷阱。还有那个口号。你知道的，我太喜欢那两个播客了。
It's called enmeshment where you and your job are just never separate. Your success at work determines your worth everywhere else. Your interests all work. You can hear people getting sick of you talking about work. Everything you think about work. I will admit, I fell into this trap when I first started doing my podcast full time. And then mantra as well. You know, I love both of those podcasts so much.
它们如此真实地反映了我自己。为了让它们变得优质和成功，投入了大量的时间。当我刚开始的时候，有太多东西悬而未决。就像我辞去了全职工作一样。所以，我几乎没有什么空间去思考其他事情。而且也因为这个播客——你们正在收听的这个——以前只是一个爱好，对吧？然后这里曾经是我用来不去想工作的地方。而突然之间，它成了我的工作，却没有任何东西能填补它留下的空白。就像我的生活中没有任何平衡感可言。我的全部
And it was, they are such a reflection of who I am. And so much time goes into making them good and successful. And when I first started, there was so much at stake. Like I'd quit my full-time job. Like, there wasn't much room for me to think about anything. else. And also because this podcast, the one you're listening to, like, this used to be a hobby, right? And then this was the place I went to kind of not think about work. And then suddenly it was my job and nothing filled its place. Like I didn't have any sense of balance in my life. My entire
身份认同就是这个。哦天哪，我是多么的索然无味。尤其是对我自己而言。就像我对自己的生活感到厌倦精疲力竭。所有的小挫折都显得无比巨大。因为有太多东西都维系在我的职业生涯这根纤细的背脊上。所以你可能会做得太过火。我认为这也是对我们的一种提醒，把价值观体现在工作中是可以的，但你必须超越工作本身。我和男友有一个规定：
identity was this. And oh my gosh, was I completely uninteresting. Especially to myself. Like I was bored of myself. I was exhausted. All the small setbacks felt enormous. because there was so much being balanced on the back of my career. So you can take it too far. I think it's our reminder as well to, it's okay to want to be your values to be reflected in work, but you also have to be bigger than work. Me and my boyfriend have this rule.
在我们到家准备聊工作之前，我们必须先聊点别的。比如一个播客、健身、我们听到的让我们感到兴奋的故事、或者新闻里的一些事。这对于我们俩来说真的很重要，因为我们俩都对自己的生计投入了极大的热情。我喜欢把它形象化为衡量你是否拥有生活平衡的“五指测试”。
Before we talk about work when we get home, we have to talk about something else. A podcast, the gym, a story we heard something like we're excited about, something in the news. It's really important for us because both of us are deeply invested in what we do for a living, I like to visualize it as a five-finger test for whether you have balance.
如果你伸出五根手指，如果工作是其中一根手指，你必须有另外四样东西来填满其他的手指。你必须有一个爱好，你必须有一个兴趣，你必须有朋友，你必须有其他四样你真正关心的事情。如果你无法为你的每一根手指在生活中分配一件同样觉得和工作一样重要的事情。这就是一个警告，也是一个提示，需要重新思考你的精力是如何被引导的。
If you hold up five fingers, if work is one of your fingers, you have to have four things to fill the other fingers. You have to have a hobby, you have to have an interest, you have to have friends, you have to have four other things that you really care about. And if you cannot assign each of your fingers something else in your life that feels as important as work. Like that is a warning and that is a sign to rethink where your energy is being directed
就像你的身份认同是一系列的水桶。工作只是其中的一个水桶。我们希望拥有其他我们珍视的事物以及其他我们关心的事情。现在就做这个测试。伸出五根手指。如果工作是其中之一，其他的是什么？为了让你的身份认同在所做的事情中得到体现，但又不是全部，你的生活中可能还需要些什么？这就是前两个迹象。我们在这里稍作休息，但回来后，我将分享最后三个指标，表明你现在做的事情可能并不完全适合你。所以请继续收听。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在这样一个陌生现代世界中培养精神韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力造成的。
to. Like your identity is a series of buckets. Work is just one bucket. We want to have other things that we value and other things that we care about. Like literally do it right now. Hold up five fingers. If work is one, what are the others? What else might you need in your life to feel like your identity is reflected in what
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即T-W-O-Persent，可在I-Hart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，绝对不要去惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也绝对不要去惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《女友们》中，天啊，这是同一个人。
you do, but it's not everything? So those are our first two signs. We're going to take a short break here, but when in return, I have three final indicators that maybe what you're doing right now is not exactly right for you. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs
一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上呢？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女友们》。
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our show. strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the
相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？
problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man.
好吧，你可以在Look Back at it播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的快克。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在聊快克，但只是为了让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆到台面上来了，所以。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. You remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你听播客的地方收听look back at it。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太心急了。
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
卷入这场追逐中，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了这个东西。我们却还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变得只关于胜利和失败。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正做一个好人。和我凯尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索Learn the Hardway并立即收听。好了，你准备好迎接第三个迹象了吗？表明你的职业并不适合你？就是这个。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so rapid.
在这个职业、这家公司、这个行业里，你脑子里想的更多的是你的辞职故事，而不是你的五年规划。每个人都喜欢听精彩的辞职故事。我还记得上大学时在一家牛排馆工作的情景。那简直太可怕了。每天上班时我都会想，今天就是我要辞职的日子。真的，我只需要一个理由把我推向崩溃的边缘，我就会辞职。我会这么做的，虽然我知道自己不会，因为我还需要这份工作。然后呢，新冠疫情来了，顺便偷走了我那史诗般的辞职故事。但我上班时一直在想着辞职这一事实，暗示了内心里更深的不快乐。辞职，对你而言，可能已经变成了一种执念，一种你无法停止盘旋、并且无法停止主导你大脑新闻循环的强迫性兴趣。你幻想着把你的生活付之一炬、彻底崩溃、人间蒸发、某天突然就不来上班了、搬去哥斯达黎加，无论是什么，这就是你能想到的全部。想到这些甚至会给你带来快乐。比起现实，你更沉迷于这种幻想，这就表明这不适合你。你知道的，白日梦并不总是坏事。它其实可以成为一种非常有创意的应对机制。但如果你经常逃避到去做别的事情的幻想中，在职业上成为另一个人，那就不仅仅是你的想象力了。那是认知上的分离。
up in the chase, that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
那是工作中的逃避现实。它还有一个名字，叫做适应不良性白日梦。如果你听过我们关于这个话题的整集节目，你就会知道我在说什么。但适应不良性白日梦本质上是指你觉得与现实脱节。因为你把太多时间花在了关于可能性的幻想中。这确实意味着你最终会忽视现实生活中的责任、现实生活中的人际关系、工作关系、截止日期以及所有类似的事情。在那些你痴迷于辞职想法的情况下，
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. Okay, are you ready for the third sign that your career is not right for you? Here it is.
我要对你完全坦诚。情况可能不会好转。可能真的是时候开始寻找一份更好的工作了。这就好比人们对恋爱关系的看法，对吧？一旦你开始，一旦你认真考虑过分手，或者一旦你对某人产生了强烈的反感，那么，你就回不到过去了。不管你在这之后坚持了多久，一旦你在心里认真地结束了一段感情或辞掉了一份工作，一切就再也回不到从前了。
You think more about your quitting story than your five-year plan in this career, in this company, in this industry. Everyone loves a good quitting story. I remember when I worked at a steak restaurant back in uni. It was so horrific. Every single day, I would walk in to the start of my shift and I think this is the day I'm going to do it. Like, I just need one reason to push me over the edge and I will quit. I will do it, knowing that I wouldn't because I needed the job. And then, you know, COVID came along and stole my epic quitting story for me. But the fact that I was thinking about quitting constantly at work indicated a much deeper unhappiness. Quitting, for you, it may be becoming a fixation, an obsessive interest that you cannot stop circling and that
你想象的可能不只是辞职。也许是别的什么。比如，幻想着一份不同的工作，幻想着你的下一次假期，下一次你关机放松。这会变得不健康，并且实际上可能最终导致，你知道的，你最终可能会破坏你目前的职业生涯，破坏你目前所处的位置。事实是，尽管你现在很讨厌你的工作，但你确实还想再找一份。这意味着要有好的推荐信和积极的工作关系。这是我希望自己在二十多岁时早点学到的一件事。千万不要因为一时的情绪而。
won't stop dominating the new cycle of your brain. You fantasize about burning your life to the ground, crashing out, disappearing, just not coming in one day, moving to Costa Rica, whatever it is, that is all you can think about. It brings you joy to think about it. Being invested in the fantasy more than reality is indicative that this isn't right for you. You know, daydreaming, it isn't always bad. It can actually be a really creative coping mechanism. But if you're constantly escaping into the idea of doing something else, being someone else professionally, that's not just your imagination. That is cognitive separation.
烧毁桥梁。你永远不知道什么时候以后还会用上那座桥。所以，试着至少把一只脚留在日常生活中，也许可以参与一点“静悄悄离职”。但要为未来着想。不要完全忽视你的工作。要聪明地思考。而且千万别，求求你千万别。
That is escapism at work. It has another name as well, maladaptive daydreaming. If you've listened to the whole episode that we did on this, you will know what I'm talking about. But maladaptive daydreaming is essentially where you feel detached from reality. because you're spending too much time in the fantasy of what could be. And it does mean that you end up neglecting real-life responsibilities, real-life relationships, work relationships, deadlines, all those kinds of things. In those instances where you're obsessing over the idea of quitting,
这就是逃避现实在起作用。它还有一个名字，叫适应不良性白日梦。如果你听完了我们关于这个话题的整期节目，你就会知道我在说什么。但适应不良性白日梦本质上是你感觉自己脱离了现实，因为你把太多时间花在了对可能发生的事情的幻想上。这确实意味着你最终会忽视现实生活中的责任、现实生活中的人际关系、工作关系、死线，以及所有诸如此类的事情。在你痴迷于辞职这个想法的那些情况下，
I'm going to be completely honest with you. It's probably not going to get better. It's probably time to start searching for a better job. It's like what they say about a relationship, right? once you get, once you have seriously considered breaking up or once you have gotten the ick over somebody, like, you're not, you're not going back from that. Like, no matter how long you hold on for afterwards, once you have seriously quit a relationship or quit a job in your mind, it's never going to be the same.
我要对你非常坦诚。情况可能不会好转。这可能是开始寻找一份更好工作的时候了。就像人们对一段关系的看法一样，对吧？一旦你开始、一旦你认真考虑过分手，或者一旦你对某人生厌，就像，你不会、你不会回到过去了。就像，无论你之后坚持多久，一旦你在心中认真地结束了一段感情或辞掉了一份工作，一切就再也回不到从前了。
It might not be quitting your imagining as well. Like, it might be something else. Like, fantasizing about a different job, fantasizing about your, next holiday, the next time you switch off. That's going to become unhealthy and it can actually end up, you know, you can end up sabotaging your current career and sabotaging where you're currently at. The thing is, as much as you hate your job right now, you do want to get another one. And that means having good references and having positive working relationships. It is something I wish I had learned earlier in my 20s. Don't burn bridges.
这可能也不是你在想象中的辞职。就像，可能是别的东西。比如，幻想一份不同的工作，幻想你的下一个假期，下一次你关机休息。这会变得不健康，甚至可能最终导致你破坏自己目前的职业生涯，破坏你目前所处的现状。问题是，尽管你现在多么讨厌你的工作，你确实还想再找一份。这意味着要有好的推荐人和积极的工作关系。这是我希望自己在20多岁时更早学到的一点。不要过河拆桥。
based on momentary feelings. You never know when you'll need that bridge later on. So instead, try and keep at least one foot in your day to day and maybe participate in a little bit of quiet quitting. But think about the future here. Don't just completely like neglect your job. Think about it smart. And don't, please don't.
基于一时的情绪。你永远不知道以后什么时候会用到那座桥。所以相反，试着至少把一只脚留在日常生活中，也许可以参与一点“静悄悄离职”。但要为未来着想。不要完全忽视你的工作。要聪明地思考。而且不要，请不要。
Just let yourself think that this is how everyone feels about work. it's not. You don't have to feel this way. You know, the best part of your day should not be the 30 minutes at lunch where you fantasize about how nice it would be to never go back in. You're allowed to want more. You are allowed to seek more for yourself. So use this fantasy as motivation so that you don't find yourself stagnant. You don't find yourself thinking, well, everyone feels this way like I'll just put up with it. Speaking of everyone, here is the fourth sign. And, I rarely hear people talk about this when it comes to knowing a career isn't right for you. Quite simply, if there is no one that you admire in your industry, this industry is not right for you. No role model, no colleagues you want to be, no person, you know, 10 years down the line whose life you think looks really great, no vision of a life you want that contains your job, no examples of it. It's not right for you. not having this admiration is often indicative of not having aspiration or inspiration for what you're doing, essentially meaning that your heart isn't in it.
让自己去想，这就是每个人对工作的感受。其实并不是这样。你不需要有这种感觉。你知道，你一天中最美好的时光不应该是午休那30分钟，幻想着永远不用回去上班有多好。你可以渴望拥有更多。你可以为自己争取更多。所以，把这种幻想当作动力，免得自己陷入停滞。免得你觉得自己想：好吧，大家都这样，我忍着就行了。说到大家，第四个标志来了。而且，当谈到如何知道一份职业不适合你时，我很少听到有人谈到这一点。很简单，如果你在你的行业里没有钦佩的人，这个行业就不适合你。没有榜样，没有你想成为的同事，没有那种你觉得十年后生活看起来非常棒的人，没有包含你这份工作的理想生活愿景，没有这方面的例子。那它就不适合你。缺乏这种钦佩，通常表明你对自己所做的事情缺乏抱负或灵感，本质上意味着你的心根本不在上面。
It also means you probably don't see yourself here long term enough to think aspirationally about what your life could become and to seek out those examples as blueprints and motivators because you are motivated. When you think about a good life, when you think about a life that you want for yourself, those dreams might not contain this career. What is that saying to you? Our brains are naturally drawn to admiration and sometimes jealousy for those doing better than us in an area where we ourselves want to thrive because, A, we are naturally comparative
这也意味着，你可能觉得自己在这里待的时间不会太长，所以不会对未来生活的无限可能抱有雄心壮志，也不会去寻找那些榜样作为蓝图和动力，因为你是有动力的。当你想象美好的生活时，当你想象你为自己渴望的生活时，这些梦想可能并不包含这份职业。这说明了什么？我们的大脑天生会被那些在我们想要蓬勃发展的领域做得比我们更好的人吸引，甚至产生嫉妒，因为，第一，我们天生是喜欢比较的生物，
creatures and B, comparison basically indicates desire, passion, and what we want. It's why if you want to figure out what kind of life you want to have, you have to ask yourself, who am I jealous of? It's very revealing. And if the answer is, well, no one in the space that I'm in, you should probably be in a different space. And obviously, I'm not condoning jealousy as a motivator. I'm just saying that jealousy is a really, because it is such a deeply felt emotion, it's quite revealing of what you really want. Also, you know, we so often learn and stay motivated through observation and modeling, but also through vicarious victory and celebration,
第二，比较基本上暗示了渴望、激情和我们真正想要的东西。这就是为什么如果你想弄清楚自己想要过什么样的生活，你必须问自己：我嫉妒谁？这非常有启发性。如果答案是：嗯，在我所在的领域里没有人。那你可能应该换个领域。当然，我并不是纵容把嫉妒作为动力。我只是说，嫉妒是一种非常深刻的情感，它能很好地揭示你内心真正想要的是什么。还有，你知道的，我们经常通过观察和模仿来学习和保持动力，同时也通过感同身受的成功和庆祝，
you know, seeing what others achieve and feeling like we could do that ourselves. That's a huge part of aspirational psychology, having role models, having someone that you look up to. And if you don't have that, like you're missing out on a big part of how you stay motivated in a career, how you advance,
你知道的，看到别人取得成就，并觉得我们自己也能做到。这是抱负心理学中非常重要的一部分，也就是有榜样，有你可以仰慕的人。如果你没有这些，就像是错失了在职业生涯中保持动力、如何晋升的重要途径，
how you seek more for yourself in this industry. Let's talk about this dimension though, which is having someone you admire in a space that you would never want to make money from doing. So what if your heroes are, I don't know, like Dallas Cowboy cheerleaders, and you know you're never going to be a Dallas Cowboy cheerleader. Like what if your heroes are classically trained musicians
以及如何在这一行业为自己争取更多。不过，我们来聊聊另一个维度，那就是在你永远不想靠它赚钱的领域里，有你钦佩的人。那么，如果你的偶像，我不知道，比如达拉斯牛仔队的啦啦队队员，而你深知自己绝不可能成为达拉斯牛仔队的啦啦队队员呢？如果你的偶像受过古典音乐训练，而你这辈子从没碰过乐器呢？当你把某个职业的人视为偶像，而你只是把这当成一种业余爱好时，会发生什么？这说得通吗？就像你把它当成爱好，而他们把它当成职业。那接下来会怎样？嗯，这很复杂。但我个人坚信，你的工作不一定非得是你世界上最热爱的事情。所以，即使你在某个领域有偶像，比如音乐家、演员，或者，我不知道，科技大咖，
and you've never picked up an instrument in your life? What happens when you admire someone as a hobbyist of the thing that they have made a career as? Does that make sense? Like you view it as a hobby, they view it as a career. What happens then? Well, that's complicated. But I think I'm personally a firm believer that your job doesn't have to be the thing that you love most in the world. So just because you have a hero in a certain field like a musician or an actor or, I don't know, a tech guru.
但这并不意味着你需要突然辞职去追求他们所做的事情。只要你知道，在未来即使没有去尝试，你也能安然接受。如果你把这个人视为个人偶像，视为你渴望成为的人，你会不会后悔没有尝试去做类似的事情？这是一个你必须自己回答的问题。从远处欣赏他们，并从他们的性格中获得动力，这也完全没有问题。只要你接受这个事实，并且在未来即使不给自己的激情一个职业发展的机会也能泰然处之，那完全是你的特权。但话说回来，如果你真的想不出你的行业或职业中有哪个人是你觉得很酷的，那外面可能还有更好的选择。也许你的偶像不会是一个会计。也许他们不会是职业药剂师。但至少应该有一个人，一个同事，一个教授，一个你大学时的同学，某个你认为过着很酷的生活、生活方式你可以效仿的人。所以，我们来到了最后一个标志，最后一个，你可能已经猜到了。
like that doesn't mean that you need to suddenly quit your job and pursue what they're doing. As long as you know that you're going to be okay in the future with not giving it a shot. If you are viewing this person as a personal hero and as someone that you aspire to be, are you going to regret not trying to do something similar? Like that's a question you have to answer for yourself. It is also completely okay to just admire them and feel motivated. by their character from afar. As long as you are okay with that fact and you will be okay in the future with not giving
那就是职业倦怠。那就是生病。那是身体和心理上感到不舒服。如果你的身体在向你发出信号，如果你的身体更容易生病、更容易精疲力竭、更容易烦躁，这份职业可能与真正的你并不契合。我们通常认为职业决策纯粹是理智和理性的，但你的身体会记录这一切。我觉得大家都听过这句话：你的身体会记录这一切，而且不仅仅是在经历创伤时。慢性胃痛、疲劳、头痛、周日焦虑症（Sunday scaries），你知道的，那种极其严重的焦虑，这些都是不正常的，不应该被忽视，这些不单单是成年人生活的一部分。
your passion a shot professionally, that's totally your prerogative. But again, if you genuinely cannot think of one person in your industry or in your profession that you think is cool, there is probably something better out there. Maybe your hero may not be an accountant. Maybe they will not be a professional pharmacist. but there should be at least one person, a colleague, a professor, someone else you're in college with, someone you think has a cool life, a life that you can see yourself emulating. So we are down to our final sign, our final one, and it's one you may have already guessed.
你也无法仅仅通过动脑筋、拼命工作来克服它们，或者抱着“情况会好转的，会好转的，会好转的”这种想法继续下去。这些症状通常根源于非常深刻的心理和职业压力。你的神经系统可能长期处于一种轻度不适和痛苦的状态，而这正在反弹到你身体的其他各个领域，导致肌肉紧张、免疫系统受抑制，即使你仍然，你知道的，每天早出晚归，即使你觉得你能挺过去，但如果你的身体在对你说不，那就听从它。
It's burnout. It's sickness. It's feeling physically and mentally unwell. if your body is giving you the signals, if your body is getting sick or easier, burnt out easier, irritated more, this career is probably not in alignment with who you are. We often think that career decisions are purely intellectual and rational, but your body keeps the score, I feel like everyone's heard that phrase, your body keeps the score and not just when it comes to trauma. chronic stomach aches, fatigue, headaches, Sunday scleries, you know, a really severe anxiety, these are not normal, these should not be dismissed, these are not just parts of being an adult.
还有，再次提醒一下，你并不是在小题大做。即使别人的处境比你更艰难，即使别人比你工作更努力，即使你觉得自己不配感到压力，我要告诉你，这其实并不是你的选择。对不起，这不是你的选择。就像，你不能去想，你不能通过告诉自己“我不配有这种感觉”来逃避它。你的身体可不是你能用意识去控制的东西。如果你让它置于一个让它生病的环境中，你不能命令它保持健康。
You also cannot just outthink them or outwork them or continue with this idea that it will get better, it will get better, it will get better. These symptoms are often rooted in very deep psychological, occupational, occupational, stress. Your nervous system is probably in a prolonged state of low level discomfort and distress, and this is ricocheting into all these other areas of your body, into detention, into a suppressed immune system, even if you're still, you know, clocking in every morning, even if you feel like you can get through it, if your body is telling you know, listen to it.
所以这是你需要真正关注的事情。科学研究表明，职业不满意会对你的身体造成损害。首先，一项研究发现，你的睡眠减少了，生病的频率更高了，你更有可能报告慢性压力。关于这一点最震撼的研究之一其实是很近期的，它分析了美国全国青年纵向调查（National Longitudinal Survey of Youth）中6000多名参与者的数据，发现20多岁和30多岁时体验到的工作相关的不满意，会在短短10到20年后导致整体健康问题，工作不幸福的真正累积效应在我们40岁左右时，
And also, another reminder, you're not being dramatic. Even if people have it tougher, even if people work harder than you, even if you feel like you don't deserve to be stressed, I'm going to tell you, that's actually not your choice. I'm sorry, it's not your choice. Like, you can't think, you can't think in a way of like, I can escape this by telling myself that I don't deserve to feel this way. Like your body is not something that you can control with your mind. Like, you can't just tell it to be well if it's in an environment that is making it sick.
就会开始在我们的健康上显现出来。研究人员调查了参与者从25岁到39岁的工作满意度，然后将其与他们40岁之后的健康数据进行对比。他们发现，在职业生涯早期对工作更不满意的人更容易生病，尤其是心理健康问题，同时还有睡眠问题、过度担忧和过度压力。而且，这是在他们控制了所有其他变量（包括收入、教育水平以及居住地）之后得出的结果。
So it's something you really need to pay attention to. Scientific studies have shown us that occupational dissatisfaction takes a toll on your body. For starters, one study found that you sleep less, you get sick more often, you're more likely to report chronic stress. one of the most shocking studies on this was actually recent and it analyzed data from over 6,000 participants in the National Longitudinal Survey of Youth and found that job related to satisfaction experienced in your 20s and 30s can lead to overall health issues just 10 to 20 years down the line with the real cumulative effect of unhappiness in your job really starting to show up in our health
这不仅仅关乎你的快乐。这关乎你的健康。而这是我们在失去它之前往往不够珍视的东西。相信我，到了那个时候，你的整个人生观都会改变。这也关乎拥有生活，拥有那些不会被让你感到受困的工作所拖累的体验。我想快点播放我另一个播客《Mantra》里的这段音频，因为我觉得我在那里表达得太好了，我甚至懒得重复自己。我觉得我表达得太完美了。这是我关于“我将休息置于生活首位”那一期的内容。我觉得它真的
around 40. The researchers, they examined the participant's job satisfaction from 25 to 39 and then compared that with data around their health after they turned 40. And what they discovered was that people who were unhappier in their jobs early in their careers were more prone to illnesses, particularly mental health problems, but also sleep problems and excessive worry and excessive stress. And this was when they were controlling for all these other variables, including income, including education levels, including where someone lived.
很适合这一期。我马上播放这段音频。没有什么比有时能静静地体验生活，允许自己好好睡个午觉更有价值的了。比如睡个午觉，享受一些闲暇时光，请一天假。你知道的，在人生的尽头，我知道这听起来太老套了。每个人都说，当你回首一生时，你会记得什么？你会记得那些你没有请假的日子，那些你工作太拼、错过了重要里程碑、重要活动的日子，还是会记得你当年翘课，和父母一起去吃冰淇淋的日子？或者你会记得那些你对自己说“我再也不让这破事折磨我了”然后和朋友去吃晚饭的日子，
This isn't just about your happiness. This is about your health. And that's something that we don't value enough until we don't have it. Trust me, like, then your entire perspective changes. This is also about having a life and having experiences that don't feel burdened by a job that you feel trapped by. I want to quickly play you guys this clip from my other podcast mantra because I think I put it so well there like I'm not even going to bother repeating myself. I think I put it perfectly. This is from my episode on I make rest a priority in my life. I think it really
尽管你知道自己没有赶上截止日期，或者尽管你内心有一股继续工作的冲动。这是我完整节目中的一个片段，它发布在我的另一个播客《Mantra》上，标题是《我将休息置于生活首位》。在那期节目中，我们真正探讨了为什么工作不仅仅是逼迫自己，它远不止是追求生产力。事实上，生活远不止是生产力，我觉得这是一个非常棒的结束点，也是一个绝佳的最终提醒。如果你的整个人生都被一份你讨厌的工作、一个你看不到未来的职业所支配，以至于它淹没你生活的所有其他部分，让你忽略了微小的快乐，让你焦虑得生病、无法去做那些有趣的事情，
applies to this episode. I'm going to play the clip right now. There is nothing more valuable than just getting to sit with your experiences sometimes and just allowing yourself to have a freaking nap. Like to have a nap, to have some downtime, to take a day off. You know, at the end of your life, I know it sounds so cliche. Everyone says you're going to look back at your life and what are you going to remember? You're going to remember the times when you didn't take a day off, when you worked too hard, when you missed important milestones, important events, or are you going to remember the day that you played hooky and, you know, you went and got ice cream with your parents. Or you're going to remember the days when you said, I'm not going to let this stress me out anymore and went to dinner
那这将会产生影响。你越早开始寻找替代方案，越早开始质疑是否有其他你更喜欢的事情，那就越好，因为你未来的自己会更早地开始感谢你。你就会过得更好。改变的时机就是现在。顺便说一句，任何年龄都是如此。无论你多大，现在行动都不晚。
with your friends, even though, you know, you didn't meet your deadline or even though you felt this like urge to keep working. That's a clip from my full episode, which is available on my other podcast mantra titled, I Make Rest a priority in my life. And on that, we really talk about why work is more than just pushing yourself and it's more than just productivity. In fact, life is more than just productivity and I think that's a real great place to finish and a real final reminder. If your entire life is dictated by a job you hate and by a career you don't see a future in such that it drowns out all the other parts of your life and it has you ignoring small joys and it has you just like sick with worry and unable to do the fun things,
但对所有20多岁的年轻人来说，你知道的，重新开始，回头承认这个学位不适合我。我不想再这样下去了。我选择成为一个初学者，这并不丢脸。这并不意味着我是个失败者。我认为这是一种不可思议的勇敢行为。选择重新开始，选择承认这并不适合你。你并没有犯错，你只是当时还没有掌握全部信息，这需要极大的勇气。这在我眼里让你成为了一个巨大成功的人。这些人正是我真正钦佩、也是我一直在寻找的故事主角。就像那些不害怕重新开始、不害怕成为初学者并敢于说“我对自己想要什么搞错了，
that's going to have an impact. and the sooner that you can start searching for an alternative, start just questioning if there is something else out there you would enjoy more, the better, like the more your future self is going to start thanking you sooner. Like, the better off you will be. The time to change is now. And that's at any age, by the way. Whatever age you are, it's still now.
现在我只想去看看、去探索”的人。你拥有如此多的时间，而当你把这些时间花在做那些符合你内心真正关切的事情上时，时间将变得更有价值。当你把时间花在那些能真正点燃你的激情、给你带来存在感或使命感、亦或是带来成就感的事情上时。不管你想怎么称呼它，拥有一份让你感到骄傲的工作和职业，首先对你的心理健康大有裨益。它对你的身体健康也大有益处，对你想要从生活中获得的快乐同样大有裨益。
But speaking to all my 20-somethings, you know, starting again, going back saying, this degree isn't right. for me. I don't want to do this anymore. I'm going to choose to be a beginner that is not shameful. That does not make me a failure. I think that that is an incredible act of bravery. Choosing to start again, choosing to acknowledge that this wasn't right. You didn't make a mistake. You just didn't have all the information yet is so courageous. Like that makes you a major success in my eyes. Like those are the kinds of people I really admire and the stories I really seek out. Like those of people who are are not afraid to start over and who are not afraid of being a beginner and saying, I was wrong
所以我希望这一期节目能带给你一些清晰的思路和答案。如果你听到了这里，大家就知道，如果你坚持听完了整期节目，你就会听到我留下的一个秘密信息，我邀请你在下方留言。如果你听到了这里，请在下方留言：你的第一份工作是什么？我的第一份工作是在一家名为“Boost Juice”的店里做冰沙。如果你是澳大利亚人，你就会知道Boost Juice的传说。但说到职业，说到那些可能并不适合我们的职业，你的第一份工作是什么？但无论如何，我希望这能再次引发你的质疑，引发你的反思，
about what I wanted, and now I'm just going to see and I'm going to explore. You have so much time, and that time will be more valuable when you spend it doing something aligned with what you care about. And when you spend it doing something that really puts a fire in your belly or that gives you a sense of being or a mission or just a sense of accomplishment. Whatever name you want to give it, having a job and having your career that you feel proud to have is really great for your mental health firstly. It's also really great for your physical health and it's really great for the enjoyment that you want to get out of life.
引发你的思考。你现在不必做出任何选择。你不需要明天就跑去辞职。这只是一个很好的方式，让你去考虑外面还有什么适合你的选择，或许也能证实一些你已经知道的事情——比如你对所选专业的更深层次的不满。这并不意味着你是个失败者。这并不意味着你犯了错误。
So I hope that this episode has provided you with some clarity and with some answers. If you have made it this far, you guys know that if you make it to the end of the episode, you get a secret message from me that I invite you to leave a comment on. If you've made it this far, leave a comment down below, what was your first job? My first job was making smoothies at a place called boost juice. If you are Australian, you will know the boost juice law. But speaking of careers, speaking of careers that maybe weren't right for us, what was your first job? But anyways, I hope that this is, yeah, again, caused you to question, cause you to reflect,
这只意味着你现在有了更多的信息，可以为自己做出更好的选择。所以当我们结束这期节目时，请确保去收听《Mantra》的那整期节目。我会在简介里留个链接。请确保在Instagram上关注我，账号是@thatpsychology podcast。如果你想分享反馈、问题、节目建议，我们随时都在寻找，随时都在留意。在那边给我发私信。请确保持续关注，这样你就能随时了解新节目的发布，如果你愿意的话，请给我们留下五星好评。这确实对节目的成长很有帮助，也能，是的，接触到像你们这样酷的新
cause you just to think about it. You don't have to make any choices now. You don't have to go out and quit your job tomorrow. This is just a nice way for you to consider what else is out there for you and maybe confirm some things you already know about, a deeper dissatisfaction with the degree you've chosen. That doesn't make you a failure. It doesn't mean you've made a mistake.
朋友。但直到下一次，保重，保持善良。对自己温柔一点，特别是如果你正在应对某种职业倦怠的话。很多人都有这种感觉，你并不孤单。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
It just means that now you have more information to make a better choice for yourself. So as we wrap up this episode, make sure that you give that full episode on Mantra a listen. I'll leave a link in the description. Make sure that you are following me on Instagram. at that psychology podcast. If you want to share feedback questions, episode suggestions, we're always on the hunt, we're always on the lookout. Send me a DM over there. Make sure you're following along so that you always know when new episodes are coming out and leave us a five-star review. If you feel called to do so, it does really help the show grow and, yeah, reach cool new
我们曾坚信种子油本质上具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO percent”。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。
people like yourselves. But until next time, stay safe, be kind. Be gentle with yourself, especially if you are dealing with some careers dissatisfaction. A lot of people are, you are not alone. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
你在玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在这个新季的《The Girlfriends》中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代的快克（crack）毒品。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊当年的快克，
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific. con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的脉络。我们现在还把艾滋病摆上台面了。谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little camp? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day,
最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kier Games）。在此，
but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the
在心理健康意识月之际。我将带来我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kier Games. And in recognition,
因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要吗？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和使命展开真实的对话。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。
Mental Health Awareness Month. I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO percent”。在《Look Back at It》播客中。对于1979年，对我来说那是一个大时刻。84年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·J
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good. person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
和亚历克斯·英格利什。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起，试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalation. available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam Jay
84年是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。
and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。
84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to and learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控育有一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你对这个特定的测试作假了两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批网络侦探出动，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一名女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节季继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档IHeart播客。真人真事，品质保证。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《困在爱中》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《困在爱中》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人制作。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。